mais t'es bonne soirée
on ne bouge plus mains en l'air et toi
tu poses michel sardou
c'est ton mec lune ouais alors et alors
quoi ta gueule ouais à plat ventre tout
de suite je ne remonte pas la cheminée
on arrive sur toi et on descend dans la
gouttière bay a passionné merde alors du
coup pour sortir par la cheminée c'est
plus joli bond et goûtez ça commence à
devenir insultant de m'ignorer de la
sorte alors s'il vous plaît à plat
ventre tout de suite r non je suis
désolé je vais pas ballon j'ai pas ce
que parce que je suis enceinte au départ
marqué côté têtu m'annonça devant
monsieur comme ça là tout ça c'est qu'il
était même pas de morale c'est bon c'est
pas à temps ça me déçoit vachement ce
que tu viens de dire la bompard monde y
revenir mais je ne vois pas le bordel de
rapport avec le cambriolage de ma maison
tu as une arme braquée sur moi je suis
enceinte
si tu tires ces deux ans d'un jeune papa
je peux pas faire ça pas du tout cela
s'appelle tous et toutes les angoisses
c'est ça les crises d'angoissé peut-être
aussi parce que tu as larmes de l'autre
braquer sur toi alors l'autre va falloir
pas trop lui manquer de respect parce
que je peux vous flinguer si vous n'avez
pas compris l'urgence du truc
non mais je normal quoi légitime défense
selon lui trouver un prénom et tout
légitime défense mais on n'a jamais
menacé nous que je sache et on l'a on
l'a fait ou wes le est le jour on le
fait c'est quand laserquest oui dans le
petit mur elle dit les deux cons pardon
de recentrer un peu le débat mais si
c'est de la légitime défense
abba bouclier bouclier nos femmes
enceintes
il me fait chier cassez vous maintenant
non vraiment tu reposes michel c'est
pour le petit pour lui chanter des
berceuses le soir bon ok on est vraiment
désolé un au revoir
je sais pas si je suis prêt un bébé ça
fait caca et ça ça vaut mieux aider fois
les deux mois je les aime et hoffmann
produits suivants du tout enceinte
patates et du bluff ouais tu veux aller
au laser quest
voilà c'est trop tard pour [ __ ] bon
allez prends leur sac
et puis prend le tableau edwards est une
aussi
le coût de la femme enceinte j'essaye la
prochaine fois parce que t'es trop tape
à l'oeil pour toi parce qu'il est trop
vieille et oui quoi voilà c'est ça allez
on se casse avant plus gros priori